a few things before we get started
please stay off your cell phones no
heckling and keep table talk to a member
now who's ready for other people
[Applause]
well give it up for your host you know
it's hot
what's up austin creek in the cave how
are you guys doing
okay uh let's try it one more time how
you guys doing give it yes
oh gosh you guys are not horny at all
tonight uh we're gonna have a good time
we picked two names out of the bucket we
got one lgbtq in there even
uh hopefully
you're happy being single because
maybe we can convert someone tonight
make an artificial californian here in
texas
uh but yeah welcome to other people uh
it's a dating show and we got a lot of
names in the bucket you can always sign
up even in the middle of the show my
name is hans kim uh
i did an arena on friday 19 000 people
so
thank you
this is nice as well
okay
i don't want to make you jealous
uh but we got a wonderful and hilarious
guest
he's a male and he's a comedian please
get over the very funny nick roach
hey it's nick roach
comedian
hello thanks for having me and stand in
for your senator's sons
he'll get shot instead of him i am i'm a
lego man basically
that's what i dress like and look like
don't let the looks fool you he can
bankrupt a small third world country at
the snap of his finger
i get i don't know yeah maybe
okay he's wearing a rolex so
[Music]
nick i don't know you're [ __ ] up
um yeah witty banter to start
i have a rolex
but don't let that intimidate you uh i
am still available
and ready to mingle i'm single as well
no just kidding i have a girlfriend uh
but are you guys ready to watch people
date each other tonight make some noise
if you're ready to see this happen
the straight man coming up
is a man named
bijan jalali
here he comes bijan jalali
going on a date with the beautiful nick
is going to pick all right a human being
here we go we got
ggl
[Music]
ggf from table number seven
she's applying makeup she's making her
way up to the stage eventually
your friends outed you already
they don't care about you
[Music]
gigi is already cleaning up
this is 2022 you don't have to do that
anymore yes there's stairs right over
there
here she comes gigi
going on a date with
bijan jalali
with the hair
give it up for these two
yes one minute of dating starting now
pick up the microphones and talk to each
other like you're on a date
what's up i'm just kidding
how are you i'm
hassan i'm well thank you
it's very nice to meet you it's nice to
meet you too why'd you pick this place
uh the creek in the cave
oh
uh because of this show i saw it last
sunday it was kind of closing down okay
and i was like i got to get on that
and then i came up here and i was like i
gotta get in on that
uh so tell me a little bit about
yourself
yeah is your mic on i don't know
better okay sorry
uh i just moved to austin like
maybe 12 days ago
really yeah
yeah yeah thank you and uh appreciate it
uh
are you a texan i am a native
californian and oh how are you going to
say something else
transplant to austin i've been here for
one year okay
i am
i don't know native wise what i am but
i am from the midwest and time give it
up for this midwesterner
and this californian wow a real-life
californian
what what would we do without
californians in texas
we hate those here by the way i came
from l.a
uh
gigi what uh
what do you think about bijan so far how
he answered your question make sure to
pick up the mic and put it right by your
chin
um
i feel a little nervous he might be too
but good energy
feel nervous i don't think he looks like
a killer but
there's nervous energy but i think
that's just the stage
there's definitely nervous energy
i'm feeling it you're feeling it
everybody here's feeling it so
it's all right we can all relax
what are you most nervous about gigi
probably being on stage
it's all right don't worry about it
thanks
good eye contact this guy is not afraid
he's in the moment he looks like he's
skateboards or there's a chef or
something
i wish
what do you do
i actually work for uh ut and the
charter schools here so they have like
uh
yeah education educator
yeah i substituted last friday that was
my first day do you have any kids of
your own no that's why i'm able to do
this kind of work yeah you keep it fresh
don't hate kids are you named after the
dog
bijan you know
it's funny there's a
bijan robinson here's a big deal here i
mean somebody's got it
right yeah okay
he it's spelled like that b-i-j-a-n
bishon is the dog so bijan mustard is
usually what i would get dijon bishop
and then kind of the like
you know lower grade insults would be
like a dog started out
funny
um so
bijan you said you wanted to get in on
that
yeah i think maybe that's a double
entendre that
might not work on a date
uh no i just think it's cool that single
people are here
yeah
i mean there's at least three it
if you google
like singles near me you're not gonna
find anything that you are looking for
right you're googling singles near me no
no no
wouldn't do that
you know that's how you get scammed
right
gamers love this man no wonder gigi is
nervous
uh have you ever heard of tinder
yeah yeah it doesn't that's sort of like
singles near me
it's good software but it just never
it never does it no the software nerd uh
gigi have you ever had any children or
are you interested in children
i have not and i don't think it's in the
cards for me oh okay because bijan has
like a direct source
you get you lots of kids wait did you
say you have kids
no okay
i could source them though you can you
you traffic children
organic children
he's offering it but
what do you what have you what do you do
in school do you actually uh work with
children or are you yeah
yeah no no i uh do like small group
you know like all the
[ __ ] that
kids from different backgrounds don't
understand like because it's not built
for them all that curriculum i just like
help with all that that's the best way
to explain special ed actually
yeah
and el and all that stuff so it's like a
language barrier thing uh sometimes okay
but i just work with whoever whatever
whatever shape size color whatever jesus
these are children don't talk about them
like they're animals
give me whatever you got i'll work with
it you said whatever shape
oh what shape
uh that was something some very
spherical that was a weird thing to say
now that i think about it um oh it's
okay i'll take that back since
retract the statement yeah exactly would
you work with nick he's a shape i'm a
shape i'm an egg shape
do you work with any children shaped
like nick
there's a lot of children shaping what
are you looking at right yeah what did
you just look at
each
anyways checking me out is about to get
fired from his job this is live streamed
on youtube so
just fyi uh gigi what do you do for a
living
i'm trying to think of how much of it i
can talk about um
she's here to steal your jobs texans
um let's say i'm in events planning
holy [ __ ] she's a stripper
just kidding you're not a stripper it
was a event not a misogynistic joke
uh so you're in events planning do you
do weddings
no
speeches
yes political speeches no
speeches okay i'm speechless i don't
know what the [ __ ] you do
um but uh yeah what how what do you
think about that bijan do you think that
uh maybe she's like a super secret spy
she's like a bodyguard for hillary
clinton
she's from california
i don't know if i should have been more
coy about what i do in comparison to
what she said he works with the texas
public school department we know his
kind but uh
can you tell me more what more can you
tell me because it i mean
they don't need to know
like whisper it sure no whatever so
you've been doing all night
are you uh
are you usually quiet do you when do you
ever yell when do when's when do you get
angry would you give speeches
no you're like hitler
when you give a speech when do i get
angry um
[Music]
when what i can't
make what makes sense in my head to
other people usually in a work
environment um
when you're giving when you're telling
people how to give a speech
or like when you're trying to talk
louder and you can't
i'll talk louder sorry
it's all right
um
so anyway
so you're an event planner
and you're a teacher
we i still don't know what you do to be
honest i've you've said it
to a teacher substitute teacher
event planner
you can plan some substitute teaching
events
i like those nails a lot thank you
yeah and
i like here they
like the beast left over from uh burning
man
left over from what from burning man oh
nice are you how did you meet your
friends your very vocal friends over
there
um
one today and
uh one in a really weird circumstance
actually oh tell us about it um
my friend showed up to my house at like
seven o'clock in the morning and had
just run like six miles to get there and
had been locked out of his new apartment
and
also lost his keys so
needed some assistance and his phone was
dead so
i had to contact her through instagram
to let her know that he wasn't showing
up for his haircut
and that's how we met
and then you showed up in his stead
and got a free so he ran six miles to
get to europe wow he didn't take an uber
he didn't know his phone
oh damn
so you had a
friend who a careless friend brought you
guys together
thank goodness yes
that's awesome and then what happened
after the message were you like and by
the way
let's go to lady bird lake and paddle
board together yeah you're hot let's
paddle board together
oh
gosh that's so easy to girls to pick up
other girls
okay um but yeah that's cool so you guys
made friends with the texan
you made a texan friend
and uh what do you guys usually do
together
well you just met today didn't you
what i meant one today but um
a gamut of things
we go out and have drinks um
she's a good friend because we can be
doing anything together and it doesn't
really matter like we can go to target
together that's fun bijan do you think
that you could get in on this maybe you
could take her to a farm
i could
yeah
i don't go to a farm with him i haven't
i'd have to look some [ __ ] end well
i'd have to look them up and see if it's
you guys should go to target together
that'd be a nice date target yeah you
two go to target look shop for towels
you guys could pick a new hair color
together
you guys both have similar colored hair
that's something you could bond over
it's hard yeah did you get your hair
colored from the
hairstylist wow that's why she wanted
you to get up here it's like a free
billboard for her
everyone go to gigi's friend that's the
name of her salon
um bijan where did you get your hair
done and a dragon ball z conference
i did it myself
it
it burned let's just put it that way
well you're i have the same because it's
not easy to be
white are you going for double a or
triple a battery
i actually don't get it
oh you look like it's like going super
saiyan
what do you like to do on your free time
uh
i brought my guitars out here i might
try and start a band just because
there's so many cool
musicians here but nice you already got
the hair yeah it's the most important
part of starting a band
gigi do you play any instruments maybe
you guys could be like
dating like the white stripes or
something i played trombone in middle
school do you need a trombonist because
sure maybe she'll give you a trombone or
she played trombone in middle school and
uh how did how's that go
um my
my teacher threw a desk at me one time
so i think i was pretty upset threw a
desk at you an entire desk yeah why
i think he was feeling frustrated oh but
what did you do to ins
i mean i know you didn't do anything
wrong but why did you throw it
why do you throw a whole desk um
he just lost it and had enough and it
was dang summer school did he get fired
no we didn't talk about it we didn't we
didn't ride on it this isn't 2022. you
don't just cancel people for throwing a
desk at a kid
yeah
bijan have you ever threw a desk at a
child before yeah the bar is low
no but i had a music teacher and when i
quit
i think it was viola or something after
like two months he said thank you for
letting me know that's what he told me
after i quit not the same story that
gigi told
uh
i can't believe you're the one that's
not from
california with that boring ass story so
you got you said the story was that you
wanted to quit your job
oh
okay sorry i'll answer your question
you're right um
no i've never thrown a desk but i've
picked up a desk with the kid in it
which i saw someone else do
yeah and i thought it'd be fine if i did
it and it was fine but it looked a
little bit different was it like an
intimidating thing or no no it's just
something for fun what shape was this
child this was in uh this was in
minneapolis in north minneapolis so it
was like that's normal there yeah that's
all you have to do to escape a blizzard
sometimes hide under a child and a desk
uh well that's cool you guys both were
children once uh how was your childhood
bijan did you have any traumatic things
happen
i mean i heard that
like in utero my mother was just
drinking pots of coffee a day
and now you have no energy
um
but no i mean not
not huge
over time over time you realize you're
the most insane person from the midwest
there's no alcoholic father there's no
drunk driving incident
um
no no cheese
being shoved down your throat did you go
to college
yeah i did where'd you go to school i
went to depaul university for a little
bit depaul okay in chicago and then i
went to the university of minnesota
and i have i'm tr i'm traumatized by
student debt i've got like a ton of
student debt cause i've gone to like
school too many [ __ ] times
wow are we talking over a hundred
thousand dollars
oh yeah and you're still in school
you're trying to sorry seriously you
don't want to you shouldn't say that on
a date
why that's honest this is about trauma
this isn't about my money situation
i'm kidding my money translation is good
so uh gigi did you have any student debt
wow
that's how you're supposed to live your
life
[ __ ] up bijon
that's great did you go to college i did
is did you have a scholarship or did
your parents pay for it
um she's from california so yeah um i
had an inheritance set aside for it did
you go to school in california
yes can i guess where you went
um it was in ventura california ventura
was it pepperdine i don't know oh no
what is it no wait what's the name of
the school pepperdine is but i didn't go
the one you went to what's its name
you don't have to save you don't want to
yeah
i'm just making a conversation yeah
nick's trying to get laid on this show
tonight
[Applause]
as you can see i'm
i'm really good at small talk
he really wants to know what college you
went to
are you going to tell him or would you
rather keep it secret keep it secret
yeah
why she's in the cia i guess
yeah she doesn't want us to know how
smart or how much smarter she is than us
that's not true what did you graduate
with what did you study um i didn't
finish
oh [ __ ]
so you just use your inheritance
wasteful university of phoenix online
i'm miserable and i have no
no student debt
no student uh that's too bad
gives you a little personality
um
that's cool so do you guys think that
you guys would go on a date together
maybe to her salon
that sounds nice
there you go
yeah maybe you could find another
bathroom wallpaper to make it to a shirt
what uh what does that shirt signify
like you're a drummer in a band or
chef is what you said i think that's
pretty spot-on but i'm not
not actually a chef but you're like uh
bohemian you love to travel maybe
i don't know honestly
okay surfer chef i think that's pretty
yeah that's i don't know why there are
those things but that's cool
you look like you belong in east austin
what's the meaning of uh the tattoo
oh uh soccer is another thing i'm really
big into
and uh
does it look weird to you
yes okay
yeah
it's indescribable yeah it's out of a
logo for a team uh called ix amsterdam
it's a it's like a rorschach test yeah
looks like his mullet is farting yeah
it's supposed to be ix the god of
victory
or something huh
looks like a bunch of scribbles it's 11
lines it's a soccer
okay isn't that cute
yeah
does anyone recognize it when you show
them
a couple people have
other people have mistaken it a student
once mistook it for something nasty that
wasn't
that wasn't good but that was only one
time a student oh a child that you work
with yeah yeah a student sorry a student
ed
sorry
that's cool that makes sense
gigi do you have any tattoos
i have two
nice and uh are they any more
describable than bijan's tattoos
yes what are they
i have my first tattoo i got when i was
17 and it was
um
my astrological sign and a moon
and i got a lightning bolt a couple
years later
the day after i went to a festival and
like
tore half my face off
oh really how how did you tear half your
face i was running from one stage to the
next and i was holding my girlfriend's
hand and
as i was running the asphalt and the
curb were the same color so at like a
full run
i tripped and fell and because i was
holding her hand i
couldn't put anything out in front of me
so it was like this side of my face was
dang shaved by
asphalt and then
i just decided to get a tattoo the next
day and have some more pain
nice that's how most injuries happen in
california is running to a festival
did anybody at the time call you
two-face
no but i think my husband went as to
face that year for halloween wait a
minute you have a husband and you're on
a date right now yeah oh
bijan how does this make you feel
extramarital
it's kind of ironic because uh
i was just hanging out with this girl
who's uh like married and separated
which is fine but like i've met two
girls here since i've been here that
they're like separated but they're still
married on paper
i don't know it's not what's going on
with her she's well i don't know i don't
know if that is what's going on it's
definitely not it it is yeah oh it is
yes oh you're separated yes okay thank
god separated but still married
technically yes if you're in a marriage
and you see bijan your marriage is about
to end
you're like the god of divorce
what happened with the two women that
were separated
the first one it was just a
chick i met here like my first night
here
um okay didn't i didn't try and date her
or anything she was 55.
why did you go on a date with her
why wouldn't i or why did you
oh uh
i went to camino el casino where they
have burgers
and i was talking to her that's where i
met her i was talking to her and then
she was like hop in
so
she was like i'm separated and i'm 55
and you're like [ __ ] off
and before we left there was a guy who
was like
really hurt like i think he was
friend-zoned like really hardcore
it was weird so that's another reason
why i didn't you know there was a guy
with her it was a dude who worked at the
bar and he was kind of like pleading to
her like uh
i just feel like you're ignoring me and
i don't know she's a regular at the bar
i shouldn't be saying this she could be
here
holy [ __ ]
don't worry it's only being live
streamed
is it worked at the beginning i think so
yeah it is
we're gonna send this to casino el
camino when we're done
um but yeah she worked he worked at the
bar and he was like i feel like you're
ignoring me well i was like yeah i'm a
customer you're at work
and i guess the back story was they were
going to hang out later in the week and
yeah i don't know and then you swooped
in and you were like let me take her
away and then not date her i think she
felt suffocated so she was like hop in
girls do stuff like that sometimes you
know they throw shade to
you were used and abused
as a third person or a
triangle
that's wonderful
so uh what uh what made you separate
from your husband gigi
university of phoenix online
[Laughter]
um
disconnection
yeah that's another way to say separated
it's just a synonym
he became distant or you did
yes
gigi is a black box of
no information
anyways
gigi what do you think about bijan do
you think that maybe you could marry him
and then separate from him later for
being
one can only hope
yeah that's just case
when you get half your debt paid off
that's pretty good
pretty good
[Music]
[Applause]
uh gigi uh wait just one question uh is
he is he uh local your husband yeah i
didn't think so you're gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of them no
is that what you're
a non-local ex-husband that's awesome
so that why you moved to austin is to
see new things
that and other things yes absolutely
what's the other thing
work
work
for your nondescript speech job i feel
like
i feel like work police officers like
interrogating
somebody
um you're very good at not answering any
questions
she's an excellent lawyer yeah oh that's
what you are a lawyer
lawyer i don't know
so you guys think you'd go on a date
again you guys think maybe you could go
you know uh walking your dogs together
or
go to a concert
what uh what do you think you guys would
do together
like your vibes maybe go to a library
read a book quietly
i haven't been to um i don't even know
the name uh just by the water around
here
yeah
barton springs barton springs yep yeah
lady bird lake yes exactly
yeah that's the water you've been
through the water yeah okay would you
have to go would you like to go by the
river no i'm just
kidding have you ever been to the water
before
so i'm confused did you say you haven't
been or you haven't you have not been to
the water no
okay
here
here oh not generally just here just
here in australia oh it's crazy because
you have to cross the water to get here
for most of the part
gigi uh would you like to show maybe
bijan like how the waterways work here
maybe uh
sure take him on a kayak ride all right
give it up for bijan and yeah
thank you
[Applause]
we got a straight man coming up by the
name of
riley farrar
and
[Music]
and we got a lady coming up uh under the
name of carly hughes give it up for
carly hughes
are they coming from the same group
[Music]
hey austin in the house
we got
a very beautiful
white couple coming up
this looks like the cover of better home
and gardens right now
give it up for carly and
riley
one minute starting now
ladies go first
so what brings you here
well i am a native uh texan originally
from houston live here in austin
i'm in home building
[Music]
live in the south congress area
and
have family here in austin
and just
live in the dream nice what about you
where you from um i'm from atlanta
hotline hi atlanta yeah okay where did
you go to school i went to ut so that's
what brought me to austin okay all right
all right all right been here ever since
you got it
you can do it pretty well i'm working on
it yeah
you can remind me or matthew mcconaughey
oh really yeah
appreciate it
um
well i'm glad y'all got a w this weekend
yeah
yeah thank god that's good that's good
well uh i don't hate it said
assuming you like austin since you've
graduated from austin you're still
really it's a pretty good time i don't
know if it's full time but i like it
right now what's what do you do as for
occupation um i am in marketing for
startups
and time give it up for riley and carly
wow
that was a very efficient date
you got all the information across
you're from houston south congress you
just started giving out your address
general area giving a geographical
history of riley that was really really
good to know for all the fbi agents
watching
for
when you stormed the capitol january 6th
[Applause]
his friends agree
how did i know oh [ __ ] he was really
there
what a coincidence who are those people
a true texan fighting for your freedoms
on stage right now just happy to be here
happy to be out of prison happy to be
here praise god how how long have you
owned barstool sports
going on two years
nice he's got money two years there you
go you guys look like you could be twins
you own barstool
no no i don't i don't you don't i don't
even i don't even get the reference i
don't even know
you should check it out you'll love it
it's a good it's a good stuff yeah it's
a good thing it's like your style of
humor is it yeah i just wasted three
weeks of your life right now
uh carly how do you uh how do you like
texas you're from atlanta
and now you're here in texas is it like
pretty much the same but people have
more guns
um no texas got a completely different
type of vibe than georgia okay
yeah less peaches more pecans
are there really a lot of peaches
um we have a lot of streets named like
peach street and like peach this that
but the fruit itself a lot of not really
no we don't have any peach trees like
orchards but not anywhere like in yes
carly was not out there picking fruit
that's what the mexicans do that's what
the illegal migrants her family hires
did
[Music]
but uh yeah you went to ut yep and uh
how do you feel about the game last
night i actually didn't watch it
oh [ __ ] yeah
how do you feel bar stool sports
i feel pretty good man i feel pretty
good you always feel good i don't even
know i don't have to be here
what's in your drink you look so relaxed
right now we got the leg crossed and
everything got some of that opioid
crisis
i got that west virginia but um
no baby that's that taxes and solid
taxes well i think you handled the the
date pretty well you're very smooth i
don't know what do you think what do you
think yeah i'd [ __ ] him yeah there we go
right on yeah you guys had a good little
chemistry there i think
yeah wonderful awesome i'm i mean hey
i'm up for constructive criticism you
look like you guys are in the same
hapless you guys don't always have to
give us some comp and we can we can go
with constructive criticism criticism
sure you sound like a batman
constructive criticism oh i'm batman
[Music]
this is the uh marathon runner version
of matthew mcconaughey
the dollar store matthew mcconaughey
what uh sports have you done are you an
athlete
uh yeah well i was back in the day um
i've torn my acl a couple times so i'm
out of commission
i've torn myself three times i have four
knee surgeries so
um
yeah i just take it easy what sport did
you play uh football where where where
my injuries came from
sure what's your main sport what's your
swimming swimming oh [ __ ] you're a
swimmer i am hell yeah you wanna see are
you are you swimming no i was a driver
okay
oh you were a diver yeah like when i was
young
that's awesome what was your best stroke
uh freestyle freestyle 100
uh yeah
drinking off yeah second best
what was your best stroke however many
it takes
the last stroke is the best stroke
the last three is where i'm at
i should have stopped carly are you an
athlete
uh i played softball growing up okay i
did a few sports but good sport not a
lot of black people there
you can excel
where is this what where did you play
softball at um in high school in atlanta
is atlanta atlanta yeah okay i remember
high school
we're on a date dude
you guys are doing great
is there anything you'd like to ask
carly right now
uh
what is your least favorite thing about
austin texas
lease everything um the construction
all the time that's his job
i hate what you do
[Applause]
yes it's your fault yeah i don't blame
you did you tear down bungalow
what's your name's god no god now god
now
what's your least favorite thing about
austin
um
least favorite thing about austin boy ut
students no no i went to texas tech that
was one thing that i failed to mention
um
but i had a lot of family then went to
ut so got ties to austin but uh my
what do i not like about towing towing
towing are you a tow truck driver
okay
yeah i've never been towed really okay
fingers crossed
yeah
it's sucks it sucks yeah it
i do have to drive a truck with for my
occupation so driving a big truck and
trying to
park it around here and
just kind of
hoping for the best then you walk out
and you're like
yeah well i don't think it got stolen
i'm pretty sure it got touched i feel
like you're really good at hoping for
the best that seems like i'm obviously
missed where exactly are you missing
parking by the way oh this hospital
seems good parker in front of there sure
yeah
better believe i got the the handicap
placard so so what do you oh you got a
handicap
for knee surgery yeah
you like earned it now
yeah
yeah no i mean it's totally legal
okay we believe you you know
it's so we're good you've probably got a
relative back it up yeah sure maybe uh
yeah i mean i feel like if you
voluntarily cause the injury it's a
little different than someone who has
like cerebral palsy but so i couldn't
agree more i couldn't agree more
so football was fun for you what did you
play the [ __ ] field goal post that
i played wide receiver wide receiver but
then i toured also wakeboarding um
wakeboarding basketball football those
were three tears
basketball and football and wakeboarding
and wakeboarding my i i grew up on lake
travis from houston but have
family that have a place out here uh on
lake travis so big lake rat
and uh yeah couldn't escape
wakeboarding and it just messed my knees
up yeah you look like you're born to
wakeboard do i yeah you
made for
cause you're white as [ __ ]
yeah i'm not saying it every your whole
demeanor is wakeboard is it
everything about you looks like you're
about to go wakeboarding right now i
should cross my legs again sorry guys
yeah that's better okay i'm sorry by the
way what do you what do you do for a
living
me yeah yeah oh i do marketing marketing
okay
um that's very vague what uh
what kind of marketing do you do i work
for different startups so kind of do
like contract work for different people
and help them like launch their products
and software's and all that
how long have you been doing that for
two years
awesome if you had to market
riley right now
to a football team
how would you do it to a football team
yeah
just don't mention the acl tears
i feel like you make a good quarterback
and then
i mean i could be the chaplain you know
i'm just happy to be here again did you
just hire hitler
praise god praise god you literally
am not the only one who
what if someone is uh jewish or a muslim
would you that's awesome
how would you how would you be a
chaplain to them
uh
we will we will pray in any way shape or
form for them can you pretend that carly
is a muslim football player and
you're a christian chaplain and you're
just trying to give her some salvation
some sort of good good sentiment before
the big game sure yeah i'll do my
absolute best
starts with a big sigh
not happy
are we talking about the entire team
we're just talking about no it's a
one-on-one you know carly's really been
having mental you know she's been
choking in the big game
carly we pray for you tonight for sake
he doesn't believe in prayer she's
muslim she hates that [ __ ] i will i i
thought they did no i don't i don't know
i don't not really i don't i'm not sure
i don't know what's happening are you
praying for her
that's what a chaplain does they pray
over after yeah all right what would the
prayer sound like
well for a
a great game
for no no injuries
for keenness sharpness quickness
accuracy
get it done and get that dub how about
that hell yeah
pumped up that is great that's
that sounds like white claw got a voice
yeah you could be in a white claw ad
can you use that advice in uh in
marketing maybe you could have accuracy
and you know like all that [ __ ] he
talked about get the dub yeah it would
help awesome
he kind of looks like if rei was a
person
[Music]
are you familiar with rei yeah i've been
there a time or two yeah okay sure no
doubt no doubt i've got to cut out some
of that wakeboarding sleeping bags they
got some great sleeping bags yeah it's a
walking austin ad
yeah oh yeah it's very awesome kitchen
but i like to stay outside
i'm an outside guy
yeah yeah so so how do you guys feel
about each other
the date how did the day go you think i
i feel like carly i didn't get to really
dive in and get to meet you what do you
want to know um
let me show her a couple of your strokes
she's told you i'm just freestyle baby
freestyle just freestyle
what would you like to know about whoa
whoa do you have any pets there any pets
no no bats i want a dog just not you
want a dog um
[Music]
car
that's okay now do you know her do you
feel like you got a deep dive
do you have any pets i do i have two two
beautiful labrador retrievers
of course you're basically a labrador
retriever as a person
emma that works out
i bet you're really good with uh you
know families and stuff you know you uh
you you ever meet you're like a
girlfriend's parents and you charm them
how does that usually go for you if you
meet your girlfriend's parents did you
you need to be a gentleman
be a gentleman it'll be sincere and a
little back rub to the mother-in-law not
maybe maybe maybe after you know after
yeah no i'm good lord
yeah take it easy take it easy would you
have it please don't haven't eaten
thanksgiving dinner yet
yeah that trip to fans
yeah yeah it starts kicking in and then
you start all of a sudden you're running
back and
you shouldn't be around a passed out
woman
not a good look for you as a former
college athlete that's one of the one of
their kryptonites
they went on a date
they're definitely going to create more
austinites
as if the city wasn't wide enough you
guys are done
yeah nice to meet you guys
good job guys let's get an lgbtqia
plus couple up here i hope they're both
lesbians or gay because if they're
lesbian and gay we're kind of [ __ ]
uh stanic
where's stanic at here he comes
stanic
going on a hopefully gay date
with keys
a woman
give it up for keys it's key's here
tonight
keith she's signed up
is this keys
i don't know where i can first went
all right that means we have an honorary
straight man
turning gay tonight
there you go
hell yeah
that's hopefully
you're straight put it in his friend put
his uh who's your friend
do you want to go on a date you're going
on a gay date next buddy
give it up for andre
walker this guy's straight as [ __ ] his
handwriting is terrible
andre here he comes going on a gay date
for the first time in his life just two
straight dudes going on a date
[Music]
what's up how you living brother
i'm good
[Applause]
sub hans
tell me about yourself
my name is andre
i like math
i don't watch tv
what about you
i watch a lot of tv
i don't like much math
from austin this is home for me
um
my friend unfortunately put me in the uh
wrong bucket tonight
but i'm glad to be able to meet you
same um
i don't think it's going to work out
though yeah i have a feeling
we can make a friendship out of this uh
possibly we're not even getting
friendship here
where are you from
houston
when did you move to austin
uh 2012.
i went to ut
okay
end time give it up for this straight
couple
stanek
and andre by the way are you sure you're
not gay
fairly confident okay
does not seem like it but all right
i know you're not but
by the way i love a straight date
straight to the point
you you you were never hazed in your
fraternity that you definitely went to
oh good bit by riley riley
and you never never enjoyed enjoyed some
of the more
risque elements of the thankfully we
didn't have much of that uh
it's not a real frat then
it's not the skull and crossbones uh
right uh what's your name uh andre andre
i don't wanna call you gay cause i don't
want to get murdered
but uh yeah how
how come you love math what are you like
the accountant for the crips
i wasn't a gang
and a fraternity the marine corps
oh okay you're in the marine corps
um long time ago but a veteran
um
i just uh like math
what kind of math do you like
it's called algebraic geometry algebraic
geometry
interesting that is so is that like
shapes and stuff like that yes with
algebra do you do it in your free time
or did you go to school for it
i went to school for linguistics
okay interesting but um i'm doing my
first conference in november interesting
so
are you like are you like a professor
no
okay
just a wizard of math is this like a
good will hunting sort of thing no i
think they're called mathematicians
holy okay he just schooled you bro well
no i'm saying like are you a
mathematician yeah
i don't know if i don't know if you
remember
that i saw you at a a a continental
gallery
okay
i'm sure you did
but
are you just saying you like math
because i'm asian and you think that's a
way to appease me uh we were on the date
that's true
so it came out on the date is it a
linguistics conference or an algebraic
geonomic
it's a
it's it's a percussion conference okay
percussion
still don't know what does that entail
uh it's like music conference
so it's music linguistics and math and
they all kind of combine to form one
like one general theme that you guys
talk about i did an analysis of motion
it's a motion capture analysis of music
technique oh okay
so d so i take it
i guess what my my question was is it
like a
hobby or it's a job but you're as a job
you are a mathematician uh
i mean i'm a school teacher also
have you ever thrown a desk at a kid
you know you know it's only i gotta say
that
i was in the marine corps nobody none of
the kids mess with her
okay
because they're afraid you're gonna
shoot them
it's a great way to do that can you give
a algebraic equation for whatever is
going on in the back of stannic's head
right now because
he's got
i think he took a nap before he came
here he's accurate he's got a little
flare
what do you think if you go to on a gay
date and the guy shows up with bed head
like that you're like oh this guy likes
to get he's the bottom for sure
i guess man
yeah these are all tips and tricks for
your next gay day andre thanks man
he's gonna kill me
did part of you feel a little gay during
the date not at all okay
sorry man
stanek what's the gayest thing you've
done
be gay
[Music]
i think tonight's date
tonight's day besides i think we hit the
the peak tonight what else have you done
that's kind of gay
like you didn't have enough money to pay
for an uber so you got in the front seat
i did have a night and no we didn't
follow through i called my uber west 7th
right here three or four years ago i
show up it's the same cars on the uber
right i walk up open the door uber for
andrew he says
no i'm not an uber driver but i'll give
you ride home
i'm like hell yeah i'm like no i'm good
he's like if you let me suck you off
i'll drive you home tonight we closed
the door and moved very quickly away but
i'd say you turned on a blow job and a
free ride home dude that's why would you
turn that down you're responsible
yeah you're definitely not jewish
what what race are you using
you're jewish no i'm not okay what was
that word you just said uh that's thanks
to god in hebrew but how do you know
hebrew so you're a fake jew
no i am fake gay i work with a lot of
i work with a lot of israelis so i i
have a little elementary what do you do
real estate
your guys jobs are so confusing
you're a mathematician who's not a
mathematician who's a school teacher
you work with israelis but you do real
estate
do you sell real estate in israel no in
austin okay
okay why why the israeli part
there's uh tech relocation as a primary
relocation now that's this is what you
want to see when you get to austin is
stanic
just staring at you
welcome there's a lot of us here
uh andre how long have you been in
austin
since 2012. damn you've been here a
while
what do you think about all these
californians moving in
i don't have an opinion
okay
dude you seem so chill and relaxed
i really like your uh to meet like your
vibe it's um
you're not nervous at all
no nice
you're making the white people nervous
uh well how long were you in uh the
marines for just four years four oh just
four years
it's a quick four-year stint were you
were you deployed or were you on base
most of services uh on base
where where were you on base new orleans
that's a war zone that place is crazy
if you guys were to go on a date
hypothetically
where do you guys think you guys would
have fun
i'm going to let you leave this one
uh the gym the gym gym date we could do
that
you'll be his uh his spotter
i i think i'm gonna leave the spotting
yeah as i said you'll be the spotter
right well well i know you guys can both
spot each other yeah you'll spot each
other
yeah uh you want to bring up your friend
to go on a date with andre i think we
should yeah ben hartman come on up ben
is what you get for signing up your
friends
[Music]
a handshake of a gay date
is the straight way to end the gate
eight here comes ben a guy that signs up
his friends
to go on gay dates
he's definitely been in a frat before i
give it up for ben and andre andre
go on another gay date
two dates in one day
you know good luck in a draw i guess
nice to meet you man
so i get you already have gotten to know
my friend andrew
yeah
i did not put his name in the bucket
just so you know
but he did have me nominated up here
just now so
okay
what do you think of that
i don't have an opinion is that
something a friend would do
i don't have an opinion
guys can you help me out here
oh we're still on the date
technically yes okay are you gonna spot
me too whenever we go work out not at
all damn it
andrew i'm on my own then
it's like that sometimes
it do be like that
so what's the fun fact about yourself
uh i'm usually calm in awkward
situations
oh i'm quite the opposite
i can tell can you tell the nervous
movement yes i can i can is my face
bright red
[Laughter]
well thank you
i'm on the wrong date
end time give it up for a jimmy fallon
an iced tea
going on a date together
holy [ __ ] this is like a buddy cop movie
right now
who's who
you're the white dude
what gave it away i thought it was red
you're doing great ben uh what made you
sign your friend up for the date i'm
innocent there
why did he call you up
excellent question why don't we bring
him back up here
oh oh [ __ ]
so we all just hated you for no reason
just now
yeah i got ripped into coming here and
next thing you know i'm on stage so
happy to be here what is it how does it
make you feel that your friend thought
it would be you that signed him up
he thinks you're a jokester
maybe
can i say something real quick um i
signed up myself
for the straight part
[Music]
can we get him a woman can we get let's
take another woman andre a woman
we're gonna pick a lucky lady no offense
to nobody there's no time to charm
a date
with andre a man who can protect you
and we'll spot you at the gym i think
you can leave
[Music]
julie coming up julie
a human female
here she comes
julie going on a date with a thomas
marine ever
he has the steady hands of a marksman
[Music]
and the loving cuddles of a
10-year austin vet get up for julie and
andre
[Music]
is this the date you were interested in
yes nice to meet you nice to meet you
so how do you like austin so far
it's great i just moved here in march
and it's been a lot of fun and um
yeah i'm from dallas though so not too
far away you know the stopping yards out
there starting guards stopping yards
stomping grass
like the stomping grounds that's what
they're called and uh pumping grounds
stopping yards or something like that
where they play
stockyards oh yeah in fort worth yeah
that's great
i hear that houston has your houston is
that what you said yeah from houston
they have a good rodeo there i haven't
been it's pretty good yeah have you ever
been to the state fair in dallas no oh
my god you have to go
yeah
what are you doing austin um i work for
a big tech company remotely i work at
home very convenient
you um do
math linguistics teaching
yes and time give it up for
julie making fun of andre's job
i'm dying to know more really
well can you tell us any more
uh yeah tell us about your sound
protection
test oh i'm sorry everybody's doing that
so the motion capture thing
was something i did at ut um
and it's just like 3d
analysis xyz coordinate plane i don't
know any math people are out there 3d
analysis like motion capture can send
you a dick pic in three dimensions
oh wow
how big is the phone she's impressed
how big is a file did you hear that
andre you finally got a straight day but
you have the same energy that you had on
your gay dates
you didn't pick it up a notch at all you
just
how much xanax are you on
zero
anyways
so you uh you did a 3d analysis
of what
like movement snare drum
damn so this is what you're going to be
thinking about in bed you're going to be
like in the z coordinate i am moving
well you think about it
you know you don't really think about
your movement but you are doing that
thing necessarily how do you what do you
think about in the throes of passion
[Music]
you know to be honest
how comfortable i've been today i don't
think i'm really that comfortable uh
expressing that
okay right now
well you're taking a page from gigi's
book tonight
uh julie so uh you invited uh
you invited andre to a state fair
i think we're going yeah
nice
what the [ __ ] who who goes to state fair
who's not like 12. it's like the state
fair of texas where's there's dallas
yeah um it's it's about to start this is
actually an ad for the texas state fair
um it runs through october you can go
for texas o.u weekend that's a fun time
to go i don't think she's kidding no i'm
not you should really go it's an ad yeah
no that's great i think that'll be fun
you two should go that'd be cool yeah
sweet
what do you do at the state fair
um
you can play games go on a ferris wheel
and get it stops the top and then you
guys kiss
yes there's also really crazy fried
foods
turkey
yeah
if you like that you guys can eat a big
turkey drum together
meat in the middle
a funnel cake
yeah funnel cake and then andre will be
like i miss ben and stanic
they can come too those are my friends
how do you know ben and stannick um i
met andrew when i moved to austin he's
my realtor and his uh
nickname yeah he's not jewish though you
got the only non-jewish realtor yeah
it's the reversal it's okay i can hold
up that side of the need
you can bring the jewish side if we need
it yeah yeah maybe i'll get a free ride
and a blow job oh so are you israeli
no just a jew okay
i didn't know if you were one of his
israeli co-workers no okay
glad i've cleared that up yeah
just a coincidence yeah okay julie just
a jew she can say that because she's
jewish uh
how why is he called stanic that's his
la i don't know it's his last name
andrew stanek i can give out your social
security number
just the last four we'll do that
i don't have it so you're jewish uh
andre what race are you i'm black
hell yeah
what if he was like i'm chinese
uh have you ever dated a jewish girl
before no
would you be open to it
uh yes
that's inclusive of you
how are you saying that nagging
uh
what
there's something blossoming here
you'd never say that
no
what's the
what's the cheapest thing you've done in
before in your life besides go join the
marines i was just about to say that
that's pretty cheap do you have a camaro
no
challenger
no okay no you're good then
one guy
got it
that is all
cheapest thing instead of buying my own
guitar
my brother's going to go and join the
army
and so he doesn't need anymore i'm just
going to take his guitar
nice you stole from a member of the
armed forces
definitely
[ __ ] him
uh julie uh
how do you like being jewish what's what
are some of the perks
some of the perks um
[Music]
i walked into this by offering you this
piece of information i'm gonna i'm gonna
pass on this question okay she wants to
get her right
yeah you like yeah that's control the
weather
yeah uh that bomb
yeah supposedly yeah
i wouldn't tell you though no it's fair
no i get it
so gigi have you ever dated an african
america or uh julie
sorry you guys all look the same to me
julia i've been like asian people i
guess
have you ever dated an asian person
before
casually
okay
i thought i'm supposed to be dating him
well
oh hans is slipping in
this is all a ploy
the show has been a giant elaborate hoax
uh yeah i mean
casually that's that's pretty much like
serious dating for an asian we don't get
a lot of white women
uh what did you think about the asian
guy did you notice anything different
from other people no he was great okay
have you ever dated a black person
before yeah casually
do you ever date seriously or yes i'll
usually just joke to you okay
just people your mother would approve of
yeah
a nice jewish boy that's what we're all
looking for yeah me too
a boy that would take a take a free ride
in an uber
yeah that was once andrew told me he
didn't accept it i was like
you're cut out of the tribe
so you guys think you're going to go to
this fair
gold
order
you guys are like an now conversation
you too
we're gonna unpack the math thing a
little more yeah right there you go yeah
that's great she's good at math she's
because she's jewish
um
yeah uh andre what uh what do you think
about the state fair are you worried
about anything like racists
um
i'm not i'm not sure if you're familiar
with the marine corps
and the makeup of the people in the
marine corps
a lot of racists no
um
a lot of state fair attendees a lot of
state fair attendance you know
attendance yeah so there's people who
worked there yeah no i went to a lot of
state fairs when i was in the marine
corps
so
what was the best state fair you went to
oh and this one in independence kansas
it's pretty nice people were very nice
could have been in uniform but you know
yeah that helps so i i don't really have
a fear of state fair
they're like
you shouldn't be scared it won't be
scary
it'll be good nice nice unless you want
to be scared in which case there's a
ride for that
do you go on rides there or do you just
like eat
when i was a kid i definitely went on
rides i love a roller coaster yeah yeah
but now you just go there for it's like
a food court
do they have to go on a ride they have
the bull right in there over there at
the state fair or is that the rodeo only
that's probably more the rodeo
we'll do that when we go to the houston
rodeo okay yeah
that's cool
a jew that loves a state fair
what do you think about
you know
other things to do do you ever do things
for fun in austin
no no fun at all
yeah i tried i came here couldn't find
any
how long have you been in austin
i moved here in march how long have you
been in austin again 2012. yeah i know i
said again at the end of my sentence
2012 okay
10 years see she she stood up for you
that's a good sign i noticed yeah yeah i
like that
just wait till she turns out against you
and
you get in a fight
um but yeah what uh
so negative
what's the longest relationship you've
been in
um i was with my ex-boyfriend for like
four years we broke up in january as
long as he's been in the marine corps
nice you guys could both bond over
abusive relationships
okay give it up for andre and julie
[Applause]
her name is julie
she's a jew
uh riley's in here p ferrar he already
went up right
interesting
we got brandon hardy
the hard meister general himself we got
a whole frat in here tonight and for our
lady uh we have one uh first name
alexandra
alexander
[Music]
hopefully she's nothing like aoc
hell yeah look at brandon
[Music]
look at brandon he's already whispering
give it up for brandon and alex
alexandra
[Applause]
starting now
hey what's up hi
i mean if we're gonna be at a bar but
into saying like this is a little tough
so
yeah a little bit what's your name uh
i'm alexandra
alex alex
yeah
it's good to meet you alex i'm brandon
nice
what do you do
what do i do i make money for people
businesses
like a financial advisor you got it look
at that
okay i used to work at a bank so oh what
bank
uh wells fargo
okay yeah i know some people at merrell
wells is fun but i think you're thinking
bank of america
not to get a look
but
same thing same thing america work in a
bank yeah regardless how you made an
awesome for um like two months
oh brand new welcome to austin seriously
hey austin's a great city by the way and
time give it up for brandon and alex are
you the guy from the second date you
just went home and changed clothes and
came back
it's like the same dude
every every guy in texas is doing an
impression of matthew mcconaughey
hey uh i got a really cool voice and i'm
gonna talk really quietly and
not say anything racist
uh brandon you started now what's your
name you thought meryl was a part of
wells fargo apparently you're not very
good at your job of making money how
much money are you making
well it all depends you know up and down
yeah if you remember when the commission
people work for depends on you know who
you work with
okay
so it changes month to month
it does
alright yeah what do you know about it
nothing just pumping that's why i'm
asking questions
[Music]
you're like i make money what i'm most
curious about is what do y'all do when
you talk to girls
like how do y'all start it because he
just saw that y'all doing it all night
that's pretty much how we talk to girls
hey honestly i'm here on a date with
alex so
can i the last guy tried that bit about
this about rather than didn't work
criticizing on what i do for a living
and i messed up a bank
i don't work in banks yeah we're going
to make fun of you it is a comedy go
ahead
we are at a comedy venue
alex what do you think about uh this guy
he makes money
uh
you know
i think our interests are a little
different
but it's okay what are you interested in
um well i'm studying law right now so
and he breaks them so
hey no i don't
you don't you follow them legally with
my job i don't but
illegal i don't know
it's being live streamed um
what's the what's the have you ever been
arrested brandon or
well i've gotten to a run and once
oh yeah that's a story for uh not now
well
those are clothes you're terrifying me
what the [ __ ]
hey did you kill a woman
i feel like you killed a woman
no honestly what happened is i was in
high school and i got to fight my friend
and
he uh sued me
and took all my scholarships away so
that's what happened it's too bad so
yeah damn
it's the whitest story ever that's not
it
that's not it though you took my
scholarship
it's like an 80s movie
you got you you punched me i'm gonna sue
you
did you win the fight brandon
well he wouldn't sue me if i didn't win
hell yeah you're a winner just not in
the court of law but
how badly was he injured
like permanent damage
he's in a wheelchair now
it was uh interesting you know it was
honestly just one punch oh wow just
that's it and uh i got him good and
[ __ ] him up you know i made a mistake
and i've lived from it
all right okay
what a moral yeah
redemption good story all right
are we on a date or yeah you guys
yeah have a little chat it's a date show
it's both
what do you want to say to alex
brandon
well
at this point you probably view me as
like this guy
[Music]
you are a guy so and honestly what's
funny about this show is that
the events that's led up to this there's
been people on the stand that i've known
all of them have actually
and they all play a different part of my
life
that's why they understand on the stage
tonight stand stage so you remember you
all right you know what
it's a dating show right yeah you've
said that five times
yes it is
i feel like the other guy won the fight
and you're suffering from brain damage
that's what they just tell them
how much longer you're in law school for
well it's my first year so
so you got about another three years
yeah basically
do you still work at wells fargo
no i left like a year ago and what do
you do in austin
well i'm studying law oh right yeah
where did you go to ut
no i actually went to school in the uk
well i go to ut now okay
but for law school you go to ut law
school i go to ut
are there any guys like brandon in the
uk
um i mean
similar skin color different aspects oh
[ __ ] uh
you just she just called you white bro
well i mean yeah but i mean no you mean
i'm white
i had no idea definitely white
uh that's cool uk
did you ever date in the united kingdom
um no i'm not a big dater but
i mean i met men yes
they are a part of our species
unfortunately
brandon have you ever
been to the uk
never been across the pond
where have you been
uh throughout the united states good bet
amount of cities and states uh
you know
but
out of country bahamas dominican nothing
crazy that's where your bank accounts
are right yeah that makes sense for like
a financial abstinence island you know
how rich is your dad
not as rich as you'd think
okay so he's
it's like in the trailer parks
no not the trailer parks come on now i'm
white
what are you doing at the trailer parks
that's not where the black people live
they live in the ghettos
when i think of trailer parks you think
of trailer park boys you know that show
hell yeah that [ __ ] was great do you do
you uh you know who barcelo sports is i
do pardon my take great podcast great
pocket yeah this guy knows
[ __ ] you the other guy that didn't know
hey you know what's funny though that
other guy that was on the stage was
talking my ex-girlfriend
he was stalking her talking to her that
was my ex your ex-girlfriend that was
carl is here oh okay you talk to her is
it a coincidence that you guys are both
here for this honestly is it carly
oh
calling out his ex
[Music]
honestly i just
can't believe we both got caught on
stage
yeah guess that's what happens you put
your name in the bucket a lot i mean
yeah that's how it works what a show did
you uh
this is a great date
holy [ __ ]
alex you've been here this whole time
we had no idea she was still on stage
well i didn't come here to
date someone
i came here to go to a comedy show
because i've never been to one first one
i've ever been to so honestly
yeah welcome man thank you so much maybe
do a little research next time
hey someone sent me a link i said i i'll
buy it and then i'm here so yeah that's
how that's why you thought what did you
think the name in the bucket thing was
uh
you just put a name in a bucket and you
pull it and they gotta be on stage yeah
you go on a date yeah but you didn't
want to
what do you want me to be
what do you want me to be no i'm just
saying that never mind
you said you didn't want to do a date
but you did the day
brandon is making us question the
philosophy of this show
what are we i think therefore i am
alex why don't you contribute and uh why
don't you tell us something about
yourself that maybe we wouldn't expect
of you
um
i'm mexican
you're mexican
yeah
i am the part
sweden
north mexico no my dad is from chihuahua
so like northern mexico
your dad's chihuahua
it's funny because you look like you'd
own a chihuahua
i actually do
[Applause]
hell yeah
some of that hometown pride
what type of dog should i get how about
where i live
i didn't live in chihuahua i'm from el
paso
that's pretty much chihuahua
yeah
yeah it is where where's your where's
your mom from
arkansas
oh my god
how do they meet
um
well my mom is actually she grew up in
latin america and she moved to el paso
for like her undergrad and then
she was roommates with my dad's sister
and that's how they met so
nice she was like you got a hot brother
i could [ __ ]
actually so my grandma went to visit and
then she went back and told my dad that
my aunt had a bunch of cute roommates so
it was like
let me go to america [ __ ] american
woman yeah basically get that green card
yeah
and where did you grow up
in alex
in el paso yeah in el paso yeah holy
[ __ ] i'm sorry that's okay
brandon where did you grow up take a
guess atlanta how'd you know
hey way to go man your team's playing
tonight hey we're owen two you know it's
a rebuilding season
but
we did lose
but we covered that's all that matters
hell yeah that's all that matters
no it's not true
atlanta though
went to
the university
of atlanta no alabama oh okay
the we're in town last weekend texas
y'all back by the way seriously texas
football is back way to go the audience
is do y'all watch football did you want
an applause out of that
honestly if you say it together
it makes texas fans feel better
you know
yeah all right thank you brandon you're
always so comforting with your
with your
stare of
alex question for you
what is your dog's name
finn finn
with two ends f-i-n-n yeah with two how
do i know
do you have a dog i don't
oh but i do like small dogs so small
dogs are my favorite okay yeah my dog
won't like you but it's fine oh
no he just he doesn't like men
especially like tall men
intimidating he's a chihuahua he's very
short
yeah why did you have to be so tall
you know what you're freaked i was just
born with it man it's it's hard it sucks
being tall
did you ever hit your head on anything
before
once or twice
okay but you got to like watch out for
these airbnbs you get because some of
them the doorways are small
and my head just
yeah
but it's too bad
makes you forget which bank merrill
lynch is associated with
well i don't work on merrill lynch so
why would i pertain to what i do where
do you work
he makes money that's what he does i
make money
he's a sound cloud honestly i do what i
do for people in their best interest
actually i really do are you a serial
killer
he's a lawyer my license is an
accountant for the cartel sure
it's actually funny because i work like
what kind of life
nice
so you're getting a lot of vibes from
brandon right now yeah this is the
reminding of your old and like the
israeli uh real estate agent julie hey
julie let's go girl
he's giving shout outs to other people
now
no
okay
alex what is do you think you'll be on
another date soon because you're not
much of a dater and now you've been on a
date and it's going out alex this is not
me do not
judge me for what is going on the stage
for the things that it coming out of his
mouth
they're asking me questions i got to
deflect and answer when i'm under an
intoxicated stage
very
couldn't tell oh you really
is this like a groundhog situation you
saw the shadow of a uh
day rapist
and
now you're going back and you're
back in your
six more six more months of winter
um you know
it hasn't been totally horrible but like
i think you need to just like brush up
on
a little bit of like the bank knowledge
just a little
hi me
what can i say
i mean no it's been good i think yeah
i'll probably go on another date but i
am honestly a little bit busy with law
school so it's okay
you're dating law school that's that's
very important
uh brandon anything that you'd like to
say to alex to maybe uh you know
get away from the law and more into dick
well you know the law always [ __ ] you
so
if you stick with it you will get [ __ ]
by it does it [ __ ] you though i don't
know it has [ __ ] me
oh yeah you did say that i'm sorry
don't worry
but you should i wouldn't be here if
that didn't happen so
what i wouldn't be here if that happened
yeah i think alex is like that'd be fine
by me
no
don't put words in my mouth i look at it
like come on this is what a girl does
she backs up her man
she's backing me up
i actually i respect you i appreciate
you thank you
he respects the first woman in his life
on stage today what a miracle oh yeah i
think he still has feelings for his ex
though so
maybe she should get up here
[Music]
is this true do you have feelings for
julie
well i've never been on a date with
julie so i haven't been able to really
take her on a date julie your ex my ex
what's her name what's your ex's name
carly oh it's carly
harley
oh he said brennan is
acting like he's on the on the stand
right now for his financial crimes
i got a light in my eye right now
so who's your ex do you still have
feelings for your ex
i mean we'd both be lying if you said no
that's that's wonderful you're very
sensitive
you got a heart of a heart of gold even
though you got an exterior of a douche
bag
[Music]
how's it going
give it up for brandon and alex
oh we're done
that was the show thank you guys so much
for coming out give it up for nick roach
hilarious man and single gentleman
anything you'd like to say to the people
uh no thanks for listening and uh yeah
thanks for having me hans it's a lot of
fun a lot of fun tonight thank you let's
see who kills me first brandon or andre
thank you guys so much for coming out
good night thank you guys
[Music]
uh